okay I'm just waiting to see when it
actually pops up
it just says starting
soon anyway I assume we're live so um oh
man let me know if you guys can hear me
and um hopefully it all comes out
copacetic it takes a while for it to
like come out and say that it's live it
takes like like a minute or two it's
weird it's uh one of those funny things
but um as you guys can see yet again we
don't have any coffee and uh this is my
first time actually live streaming this
in 1080P so let me know if you guys have
any kind of um of issues if you guys are
are having a hard time at all um with it
stuttering or anything like that and
we'll back it off to uh 720p so
hopefully 1080p comes across good um as
you guys know for those of you new guys
who are joining us on our lack of coffee
and Comics or comics and coffee comics
and no coffee comics and something
always besides coffee um I usually just
shoot from the hip and um answer some
questions you guys have it's it's like
our like the weekly Q&A for um how many
books in general whereas with the weekly
poll we have like a regimented thing
that we usually talk about this it's
usually pretty like set up um we usually
always have an idea ahead of time on
what the discussion is going to be and
we try to stick to that otherwise we end
up just going off on tangents like we do
in these videos
so
um anyway so so yeah just I mean this is
just one of those things where I just
like to kind of uh kind of go on with
you guys and just and just you know I
think it's a really cool way to interact
with you guys and just talk about stuff
like there's no real set you know form
for this thing there's no real set way
to um for this thing to operate it's
just kind of out there you know and
again this was this was an amalgamation
of different ideas this idea came from s
for one and this idea came from like
Benny and it came from the podcast and
it came from all over the place so um
yeah I don't know um can we talk about
coffee and eat Comics this time no we're
not going to eat Comics we're not going
to eat comic books although I do have my
copy of um Darth Vader issue number one
that I still haven't opened yet so um
yeah
um I'm in Afghanistan US Embassy
Internet isn't that fast TP is murdering
me um okay some people are saying that
it's kind of lagging a little bit um if
it's if it's let me know if it's like if
it's lagging for you guys just say like
just type lag or something like that and
um that way I can get a good idea on on
who's having problems and who's not if
it's like a small minority of people who
are having a small minority if it's a
minority of people who are having
problems then I guess we'll just kind of
keep it at 1080p for right now and then
um you can always come back and watch it
later but um if it's if it's like a
majority of people then we'll just go
back to uh to 720p so um yeah it's just
an informal thing it's uh read com read
coffee and E
I don't know if you can really like I
mean I guess you could read coffee like
if you're one of those people who can do
those designs in capuccino that's pretty
badass this is actually just a protein
drink
um let's see did the beyonders kill
galatis not that we know of um in
fact I have my um I have my
sources no um as far as I know Galactus
is not been killed by the beyonders
although he may very well have um I mean
he may very well have hold on a second
let's uh let's take a look and let's
find
out let's
see new Avengers number
30 open this
up scroll down it's oh my God the
Captain Britain cores are all dying
and the beyonders are here and Hank Pim
is like hey here's my story and I fell
through like different dimensions and
all kinds of crazy [__] and the story is
just now getting interesting after three
years of
writing that's the thing about Hickman
Hickman plays the long game he builds
that game up big time but uh no the the
beyonders are killing the celestials and
they they actually killed the celestials
pretty
easily um and they killed let's
see they killed infinity and they killed
eternity and they killed Master order
and Lord
Chaos yep they split eternity in two and
then the Living Tribunal appears and
they're like you know what sorry about
your luck they kill him too so yeah they
kill everybody
um everybody's dead so but Galactus as
far they haven't shown Galactus dying so
it may be that Galactus just isn't here
anymore I mean me we haven't seen him
for a while like as as far as I remember
God if I remember correctly um at one
point along the line read richers and
the Illuminati had appealed to um
galatis
uh maybe it was eternity and the Living
Tribunal I don't remember but um they
basically just dismissed it like it
doesn't matter and then walked away and
then they all
died
um all right let's
see how are there going to be so many
characters introduced in Batman versus
Superman um I think they're going to be
like cameos like they're just going to
be quick little things where I mean
we'll see like I think I don't know
it'll be like this buildup I think that
we'll see Aquaman towards the beginning
or we'll see Aquaman kind of bringing
the two together like being the
intermediary in the middle of their
conflict or kind of showing up and
saying hey look there's more than just
you two guys here like there's people
out here who do all kinds of crazy stuff
um I think that once the film begins to
come to an end it'll basically be the bu
be the leadup to Aquaman bringing
everybody together and then go from
there um but I think any of the other
characters that we're going to see are
just going to be like quick little
Snippets here and there they might show
up they might intervene the problem is
that if they go any other route they'd
be doing too much they would be just and
it'd be like Spider-Man 3 with Batman
and Superman it would be an AB absolute
travesty way too much going on and it
would be total pandemonium people
wouldn't know who to focus on and the
characters that people love a lot
wouldn't get a whole lot of screen time
so
um I've already done a video on the one
above all uh Galactus was last seen
that's right in the ultimate universe
that's why they sent him away to the
Ultimate Universe um yeah because I for
some reason I don't know why I always
keep forgetting that in the incursions
the Galactus that we saw was a Galactus
from an alternate universe that was
destroying that planet
Earth uh let's
see did they already cast a Green
Lantern I don't think
so and I don't think the GRE Lantern is
going to appear in Batman versus
Superman he might though I actually
haven't been keeping tabs on who all
supposed to to show up and Batman and
Superman I know I know Aquaman's
supposed to be there but aside from him
maybe wonder woman supposed to have a
cameo I'm not 100% sure um with a lot of
comic book movies I like to just wait
and actually go see the movie and then
just kind of be surprised the only
exception that is Age of Ultron just
because I know that Marvel's not going
to give us all the good stuff during the
trailers they're just going to show like
here's here's an action sequence here's
an action sequence here's some people
talking and it's not going to be any of
the significant part of the movie that's
going to be in the trailer and so I I
wasn't too upset about about that but
um do I think they will bring back the
celestials or a different version of
them actually I don't think they will um
I think they're going to kill off all
the cosmic entities and the reason why
is because with battle world you have
all these real it's like a patchwork of
realities existing on a single planet
what need would there be for Cosmic
entities now I think that there may be
Cosmic entities in the realm of each of
those individual realities that survived
but in terms of the earth 616 continuity
and that kind of stuff I don't know they
may just get rid of them all entirely I
mean seems to be what they're doing like
Hickman's basically said like in this
alternate reality yes the celestials and
all the cosmic entities were killed but
they've also vanished from our
continuity as well indicating that the
beyonders killed them there and the
beyonders have been going out throughout
the entire Multiverse and killing
everything off like that's the role of
the beyonders and the lead up to Secret
Wars as part of this incursions thing
the
beyonders are the ivory Kings and where
rabu Mal's actions or I guess his birth
into existence began the chain reaction
that led to the end of everything the
beyonders are trying to wipe out
everything before this Chain Reaction
can happen and so it's it's kind of
weird um but that seems to be the way
that things are going with this whole uh
incursions thing so um now again that
information comes from Black Swan so I
mean this is again this is the first
time we've seen the ivory Kings or I
guess that we know who the ivory Kings
actually are and that we've seen the
beyonders in Marvel Comics like that's
that's one of the things a lot of people
don't seem to seem to remember is that
we've never seen what the beyonders look
like before this is the very first time
so this is this is pretty big for
Hickman to really kind of pull out the
big guns and say like you remember these
super omnipotent characters that we've
talked about for the last 40 years well
here's who they
are
um let's see do you think the MCU
Infinity war will only include story
elements from the original Infinity
Gauntlet run or possibly include
Infinity war and infinity Crusade
unveiling the magusin goddess okay
here's the reason why I stopped doing
Infinity War Infinity War has nothing to
do with the movie that's coming out in
the Marvel Cinematic
Universe had nothing to do with it there
was no point in continuing it like once
I realized what they were doing and once
like because I was able to look at the
statistics on the video I looked at the
video in terms of what the retention was
people were starting the video and then
in the first minute they were dropping
off and the reason why like I think it
was like a 40 or 50% drop off in the
first minute because I was like this is
a followup to The Infinity Gauntlet and
they were like well it's not going to be
the infinity from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so the hell with it and they're
and they're right I mean there's no
point in doing Infinity War if if Marvel
came out and they released like the
infinity War like the real Infinity war
with um with Adam Warlock splitting his
Consciousness into two you know using
the um Infinity Gauntlet and creating
the bringing the Magus back and creating
the goddess it would be a silly story
and uh the infinity war in Marvel Comics
is going to be based on The Infinity
Gauntlet so there was no reason to do
the uh the infinity War storyline so I
just stopped it and I stopped doing Age
of Apocalypse because that movie comes
out in two years and there's much bigger
fish to fry than Age of Apocalypse I
we've got Secret Wars coming up we've
got you know the we have the leadup to
Secret Wars we had to take care of there
were more important things going on for
my
channel than like a 20-year-old story
that wasn't really relevant anymore
so uh what's your take on the whole soul
gy thing in Age of Ultron all
right we don't know if there's a Soul
Gym in Age of Ultron and I assume you're
talking about the staff of Loki and we
don't know for sure if the staff of Loki
is even an Infinity gym we're pretty
sure it is um I don't think fy's come
out and said that it is an Infinity gym
if he has I missed it but um it would be
either the Mind gym or the Soul Gym but
regardless it makes sense I mean the one
thing you guys got to keep in mind is
that that all these movies are leading
up to Infinity war and so in one way or
another they're going to have the
infinity gems in some capacity or Thanos
in some capacity in these movies um this
is like the ultimate goal all paths are
leading to um to the infinity War thing
that that's see to me that's why when I
sit down and watch the movies it it
brings like a whole new element into the
movies because when you watch Iron Man 1
and Iron Man 2 and Iron Man 3 and you
watch The Avengers and you watch The
Incredible Hulk and you watch all that
and you realize this is all leading up
to Infinity War it changes the dynamic
of the movies entirely because they're
not just these isolated movies you know
that sometimes cross over they're
leading to like this much bigger picture
and it it really makes things cool
so make infinity peace not
war um it's been confirmed as one of the
gems okay like I said that that was
something that I may have missed um
Believe It or Not guys I miss stuff
occasionally I've got a lot of stuff up
here but there's a lot of stuff that I
don't know either
so um
okay by the very nature of the
Multiverse don't they celestials they
have to still exist somewhere in the far
reaches of the Multiverse or is the
Multiverse limited okay
we should probably do a video about the
Multiverse and Marvel Comics we may or
may not do that but without going into
uh without doing like a video about it
we'll just uh we'll we'll do a Marvel
explained video within this video or I
guess a Comics explained video God old
habits
um okay the problem with the Multiverse
is that stuff just
happens um it's it's it's weird with
Marvel's contradictions Marvel just
throws stuff out there they just say
okay guys look like yes there's a
Multiverse but we have to explain how it
came into existence and so we know the
one above all exists out there well the
Assumption was the one above all created
all the realities the one above all made
the whole Multiverse and everything and
then they come along in 2013 like we
talked about in the celestials and they
say nope um the celestials were there at
the dawn of existence and they made the
Multiverse and so it's like okay and
then of course we know that Galactus was
born into this universe after the
previous Universe ended so it's like
okay I mean all right are they I mean is
it like Galactic I mean I don't I don't
understand that's the problem that's the
problem with Marvel continuity like
somebody posted a comment yesterday on
the video and I can't remember exactly
what it was they said but I just said
welcome to comic book or welcome to
contradictions 101 like comic
contradictions oneon-one that's the
problem with Marvel that's one of the
reasons why reboots are such an
important aspect of comic book
continuity when you look at Marvel
Comics Marvel Comics has basically been
running since the 1960 s and if you
really really want to get into it with
characters like nameer the Submariner
they've been running since the 1930s
Marvel's never rebooted a single
character's continuity well kind of but
not really Marvel's never really
rebooted their entire continuity they've
never said okay guys this is year zero
this is Bam just if you ever want to get
into Marvel Comics start here they never
really did that with I guess you could
say ultimate the Ultimate Universe they
kind of did but it wasn't the main
continuity that people knew about that
people had known about for 30 40 50 60
years and so the problem is that among
all that continuity you're going to have
contradictions because writers are going
to sit down like Brian mle benis is
going to sit down and Brian Michael M is
gonna say okay like or Jonathan Hickman
rather he may sit down and he may say
okay look we're gonna write this story
you know and he's not going to be
focusing on the continuity of D of
Marvel Comics from 50 years ago he's not
going to be thinking about a story from
197 something that's not going to be his
Focus his focus is going to be okay
let's write this story Here and Now
Bendis is the same way Jeff lobe anybody
who writes from Marvel Comics it's the
same way they they know the continuity
but there's going to be inherent
contradictions because it'd be
ridiculous to expect a writer to make a
story and to know the events from 40 or
50 years before he's writing that story
I mean it would just be really insane it
would be absolutely nuts it would make
for a perfect continuity but it's just
not the way things work and so
ultimately you just run into like all
these different contradictions and that
I think is one of the reasons why
Marvel's rebooting their continuity
because in truth it just kind of gets
ridiculous like people people don't know
where to start people don't know where
to go people don't know what to do they
don't know any of this stuff they're
just kind of out there and and that's it
so I don't know but you know either way
um it's one of those interesting things
you know where people jump into the
crazy circumstances and they they don't
know what to do with Marvel Comics and
so that's why I think this is a good
idea now the problem with Secret Wars
and this is the problem that a lot of
people had people thought it was going
to be a reboot people would said okay
look there's going to be all these
different universes are going to come
together there's going to be this great
big huge battle and at it's going to
come a single continuity but that's not
what's happening instead they're
rewriting or continuing a bunch of old
stories and the continuity stays the
same and so if you're going to sit down
and you're going to read renew your vows
by Spider-Man you still got to know
about one more day or you still got to
know about you know the Spider-Man
Annual number 20 whatever it is 21 I
think or something like that 22 you
still got to know that whole great big
huge you know back continuity and that's
that's a problem you know that that
they're going to be facing but
nonetheless you know at the end of the
day it just depends on on what it is you
want want to do if you care enough about
the characters people will find a way to
learn about them which is the reason why
my Channel's here to teach you guys
about all that stuff so um now that
we're done with that tangent you see
what I mean when I say that like this is
totally different from the weekly pool
like the tangents are just maddening on
here uh Marvel is due for reboot yes
they are um there is a rumor Thor goes
off world in Age of Ultron maybe gets
the soul gy I don't know I mean I don't
really go with rumors
um it's uh oh what's going on comic book
fan um I don't really uh I don't really
go with rumors I'm not a huge fan of of
the whole Rumor Mill um you know I mean
it's it's cool to read about you know
and maybe one day we'll get into that
but right now you know I I like confirm
things that's that's one of the funny
things like somebody asked the question
yesterday you know doesn't galatis
consume planets that are homes for the
celestials or can turn into celestials
I've heard that's true but I couldn't
find a source and when I make my videos
if I can't find a source I don't say
it's true I'm just kind of like whatever
you know if I can't confirm it then I
don't worry about it so um do I have a
video plan for multiversity I'm I'm
trying to make a video for multiversity
but Grant Morrison is making it stupid
difficult it's a you know it's just
grant Morrison is making this such a
pain in the ass I may need to have
someone explain it to me so I can
explain it to you guys I don't
know um let's see do I think Raina is
going to attack Sky because she looks
exactly the same and she turned into a
monster um I don't know maybe I'm not
really sure I think raina's confused and
lost I think Raina is going to be the
first people first person actually meet
the inhuman royal family but uh where's
Minecraft Rob um it'll be around at
sometime but we'll get it at some point
or another um what is your opinion of
Transformers and Marvel's run as well as
IDW run and is there possibility for a
Transformers explain I never really read
Transformers in comics so I don't know
like I was never the biggest fan of
Transformers um
comic book fans stop typing in caps or
I'm G to kick you out uh can you explain
it right now or can you make a video on
what Nick Fury said to Thor in original
sin uh I could explain it right now but
we've got other stuff to talk about um
could the soul soul gem be on the
vision's forehead no you're thinking of
Adam Warlock Adam Warlock has the soul
gem on his forehead as long as well as
the other U members of the infinity
watch except for pip the troll who put
it between his toes although in the
comic books this was the funny thing in
the comic books it was designed to
indicate that he had stuck it up his
rectum basically like stuck it up his
ass is what I mean did the beyonders
kill death we don't know
um that's the problem we don't know
Hickman I mean this this is all real
like this is this is very new like this
has all just been revealed to us on
Wednesday that that's when all this when
we learned all this stuff no I'm sorry a
couple weeks ago that's when we learned
all this stuff like we don't know um if
that'll happen like we don't know if
that happen happened we don't know
exactly how many Cosmic entities the
beyonders have killed we're assuming
they've killed them all because they
killed the most prominent ones including
the Living Tribunal but we don't know if
they've actually killed death so the
problem is that if they were to kill
death then nothing could die like that
was the basis of the cancer verse in uh
the Thanos imperative was that when
Captain Marvel in that in that
continuity rather than Captain Marvel
dying in 1984 like he did in the ear 616
continuity he actually died of cancer in
that story um he had ban all the powers
of the superheroes together and
obliterated death and so because no one
could die it turned into a universe that
was just teaming with life there was
life everywhere everything just lived
forever and ever and ever and ever and
so it's just like it spilled out into
the Earth 616 continuity after the
events of
annihilation uh let's
see where is Thanos right now is he
still in his stone form no he was
released from that form during
um oh during the incursions he was
released in that form by Loki um and
then he became part of
um then he uh became part of the cabal
for a name of the Submariner Rob quit
dodging the question on what Fury said
to Thor well I'm definitely not going to
answer that question now if that's how
you're going to say
it
well is a Multiverse infinite because if
it is the celestials can't ever truly be
purged see that's that's the that's the
beauty of the
incursions that is the beauty of the
incursions a lot of people see a lot of
people don't don't think about this the
beauty of the whole incursion situation
is rather than sitting down and saying
okay Christ is on infinite Earths and
saying the anti- monitor is wiping out
all these other universes and we've got
to find a way and we have you know
rather than saying like what about all
these other universes like how did he
manage to kill those and things like
that Marvel came along and fixed that
problem they said Hickman give us a way
to start wiping out the alternate
universes incursions we don't even have
to see them happen all we know is that
Earths are bumping into each other and
so in between all the stories that we're
doing other Earths are are colliding
into each other in the middle of
spiderverse you have spiderverse going
on and the Earth are colliding into each
other one of the spider characters can't
even go back to his home planet because
it's been obliterated because of the
incursions you have all these alternate
realities that we're never going to see
superhero variations of characters that
we know that we're never going to see
who have just been totally wiped out
because they're Planet crash into
another one and that's it that's the
beauty of the incursions once this is
over Marvel can just sit down and say
okay guys here are the realities
anything else that's not here was
destroyed during the convers during the
incursions done and done and that's it
that's that's the beauty of it so the
universes as a whole are obliterated
including all the cosmic entities in
that universe and so that's how they've
been able to wipe out all these
different celestials I mean the
beyonders have just been going about
killing celestials the incursions have
taken care of everything else and so
that's that's the beauty of this whole
thing so
um let's see Thor versus
Superman I don't know um I'd give it to
Superman almost any day of the week um
who's going to go see the Marvel
Marathon I wanted to see the Marvel
Marathon but they're not ha they're not
having it um here in Lexington comic
book fan why are you okay you know what
I'm going to
start let's
see um I wanted to see the Marvel
Marathon but you know they're not having
it Lexington and that's what upsets me
like I'd have to travel
freaking hours in order to actually be
able to see
it like that's the problem so you know I
I don't I don't know um there's they're
only having it in like four cities I
think
so um it kind of
sucks
um let's
see uh there isn't a way to reduce
Infinity to a
number that is a definition Infinity I
hey man I don't make the rules dude that
this is comic book logic we're going by
this is Marvel logic I don't I don't I
don't know what to tell you
um do I think cable would be an exent
apocalypse uh most likely but the cable
they're going to be using is going to be
um oh God the cable they're going to be
using is going to be the ultimate cable
I think which I I'll give you guys one
guess who the ultimate cable
is the Ultimate Universe version of
cable I'll give you one guess who it
is
um what do you think is a surprise in
the ComicCon this year I have no earthly
clue I don't even know where to
begin um if Marvel does a reboot will
most of the hero and villains heroes and
villains change or will any of the
origins change see they're not doing a
continuity or they're not doing a
character reboot they're doing a
continuity Rebo they're consolidating I
guess consolidation is the best way to
describe it they're taking these
infinite or this huge number of
realities and they're condensing them
down into a handful of realities based
on stories that we already know that's
the problem with this whole thing is
we're going back to what we know we're
not going back to what we don't know and
so we're not going to what we don't know
and so it's just kind of like H whatever
so yeah I I don't know
um Rob do you think the ivory Kings have
a hand in creating battle world since
the mat makers created patches of dead
universes and put them together um I
don't know that's actually a pretty
solid idea now that now that you mention
it um that's entirely possible I mean
it'd be a great way to tie into the
original beyonder who created battle
world uh I don't know I
mean I we may find out there's more to
these beyonders than has been revealed
to us it could be the beyonders view all
these different realities as the
potential to create morea laws and so as
a result they've been annihilating them
entirely we don't know what the
motivations of the ivory kings are
beyond what what what's basically been
told us by Hank Pim or what we've seen
them do and so we're not really sure
what Black Swan has said and we can't
really verify the black Swan's even
telling the truth in the first place
because there's no Charles Xavier here
and so there's no one to read her
mind
uh
okay
um all right we'll make a video
definitely explaining that Marvel Now
versus Secret Wars um Marvel
Now was a way for Marvel to kind of
shake things up a little bit DC had the
new 52 all right DC said okay guys this
is year zero like secret Origins
Superman secret Origins Wonder Woman
Action Comics number one woman a Wonder
Woman number one Batman zero year so on
and so forth these are the the zeros of
all these characters if you ever want to
get into the stories of these characters
read these the only exception to that
was with Batman and he they said read um
uh the killing joke but you know and I
guess you could reference death in the
family but even then that was just kind
of like you know whatever there were a
handful maybe a couple stories that you
B path beyonder there were a couple
stories that you could read from the
Batman continuity but for the most part
you could just start with zero year and
just I guess really just go from there
and so as a result fans love that idea I
mean new fans loved it new fans were
like oh God like I can jump into DC
Comics right now with Marvel Comics are
not doing that Marvel Now was basically
them coming along and saying okay guys
we're going to shake things up a little
bit like Marvel now we've got uncanny
Avengers Marvel Now we've got all new
Captain America Steve Rogers is still
around he's just old we've got a
different person stepping into the role
of Steve Rogers Marvel now we had all
new Captain Marvel okay Carol Danver
stops being Miss Marvel and accepts the
mantle of Captain Marvel that's how it
works it wasn't a reboot of any kind for
the characters it was just kind of
shaking the characters up and putting
them in different roles or moving the
characters into the next step of what
people wanted to see that's you know and
Marvel Now was cool because you got all
new I mean you got number one so you
know all new X-Men number one and it was
but you still had to know the continuity
of the X-Men you still had to read
stories of the X-Men going into all new
X-Men because you would be absolutely
confused you wouldn't know what the hell
is going on why is be springing the
X-Men from an alternate reality into
this reality like why is he trying get
Scott Summers to come back to reason
again I mean you you had to know that
stuff and that's why Marvel Now was a
great way to bring people in but the
problem is they ran into the exact same
situation you're running into where
they're saying okay there's Marvel now
but there's also Secret Wars so which
one should I be reading here like which
one should I get into now what we don't
know is if the changes that Marvel made
with Marvel Now are going to roll over
into Secret Wars we don't know if that's
going to be the case is Carol ders going
to stay Captain Marvel or is something
else going to happen or are the allnew
X-Men going to come from the Ultimate
Universe into this universe and into the
part of the battle world we don't know
that we have no idea about that kind of
stuff
so uh what do you think about Spider-Man
coming to the Marvel Universe I think
it's awesome I mean I'm excited for it I
don't know about you
guys how do I feel about red
hood okay I'm going to spoil this we're
going to do a video about red hood
probably tomorrow so you'll find out
what I think about red hood tomorrow
um let's see let's uh scroll back down
again do you
think let's
see oh that's a Transformers question I
never read I never really read
Transformers so I don't know I really
can't answer any questions about
Transformers um is neyer part of the MCU
or Fox uh he is a mutant so I believe
he's part of
fox um can I do a video about the scroll
Invasion uh
maybe let's
see let's be honest Marvel is for legacy
readers and DC is directed for new and
returning comic readers uh kind of but
not really I mean that's that's not
really true at all I mean Marvel's there
for legacy readers to a degree but the
great thing about a new volume is that
they always cover what happened in the
previous one so you can sit down and
read all new Spider-Man and you you'll
be fun I mean you've got you know Miles
Morales as Spider man in the Ultimate
Universe I mean you can still start off
in Marvel Comics at any point in time
and you can read Wikipedia for an hour
and be caught up on the characters going
into the current run of the comics
that's the great thing about having a
continuity that's lasted so long is you
don't have to worry about reboots but
again the downside is there's nowhere
new for you to start so it's not really
it's not really a comparison thing it's
not really like Marvel versus DC so much
as it is it depends on which one you I
really identify with the most um why
would they kill off the Fantastic 4
because they don't have the rights to
the Fantastic
4 uh oh Universal has the rights to any
more
okay I I I really wasn't sure to be
honest um do you think it would be cool
if amalgam Universe would be in
convergence or in secret Wars I
mean I guess it'd be kind of cool but I
don't really know what You' do with it I
mean I guess I don't know I
mean
you could it'd be a great way to it'd be
a great way like a great story later on
down the road like Secret Wars versus
convergence and to like kind of allow
people to segue between the two but I
don't know that's a tough
question um if the maximoff twins get
praised in Age of Ultron do you think
Fox will include Scarlet witch in X-Men
apocalypse
um I don't know I don't think so I doubt
it I mean they may but if they were
going to do anything with the Scarlet
wish they would have done that during um
they would have done more with her
character during Days of Future
Past uh let's
see thanks for all you do Rob thanks um
listening from Kanye turkey someone else
asked but I would also be curious to
hear your ideas about the possible soul
gy and Avengers Age of ultra on trailer
3 um I don't know I
mean I think that this soul gy is going
to be kind of a background thing and I
think ultimately by the end of the film
it's going to end up in the hands of uh
Thanos I think it's going to be the
first time we actually see Thanos in
possession of an Infinity gym that
doesn't mean he doesn't have the others
but it's going to be the first time we
actually see him in possession of it so
I don't know
um Thanos versus Onslaught who wins Rob
uh Onslaught hands down
um what's your take on the new Thor
Ragnarok movie it's going to be be their
way to write Thor out of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I think to kill off
his character so Chris Hemsworth can go
off and do other
projects um I don't know though I
mean I don't know let's think about this
for a second as I move
my my microphone back let's think about
this for a
second I mean what was Ragnarok in the
comics Ragnarok in the comics was a
cycle of life and
death Ragnarok was the event of all the
asgardians dying being killed off in
some massive apocalyptic event and then
coming back to life again and the cycle
continuing
um I think it'd be a great way for them
to kill off Thor in the comics either
replace him with someone new and saying
well this is just a cycle of Ragnarok a
new Thor always appears in this version
of Ragnarok and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe or um it'd be a way for Chris
himsworth Thor to be gone during some
event some point in time for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe or Chris himsworth to
go off and do his own stories and then
to eventually come back if he wants to I
don't
know um it really just
depends what do I think about the
character of Angela moving from the swan
Universe to the Marvel 616 Universe
honestly it didn't really matter to me
that much I didn't really care that much
about about Angela as a
character um with convergence is the new
52 ending and we going back to Earth one
continuity no the new 52 continuity is
continuing on after convergence that's
the new continuity in DC Comics so if
you guys want to read if you guys are
going to get into any continuity uh I
guess during and after convergence the
new 52 continuity is going to be the
main one that's the main thread all
convergence is going to do is give us a
bunch of smaller stories that give us a
throwback to the old continuity but
they're going to keep the new 52 as the
main continuity going forward I mean
they may change their minds though I
imagine it might just depend on the on
the reception of a lot of the older
stories so um
what single Marvel character can defeat
Onslaught besides the cosmic
entities
uh I
mean a fully powered Franklin Richards
like the an adult Franklin Richards
could wipe him out
um I don't know that's the problem with
Onslaught he was a stupidly powerful
character in the 1990s it was nuts how
powerful he is he punched the Juggernaut
and knocked him halfway across the world
so yeah like halfway not halfway across
the country halfway across the globe the
entire planet Earth that's how powerful
he was it's
nuts uh who's your favorite
Robin probably Dick
Grayson but admittedly I haven't gotten
as into dami and Wayne as I need to
which by the way for those of you guys
who are wondering yes we're going to
explain all the Robins the next one
we're going to do is Jason Todd and
we're going to do Jason Todd as Robin
and as the Red Hood after that we're
just going to move down the line so Tim
Drake um and then so on and so forth
until we eventually get to Damen Wayne
so
but again all this is going towards the
leadup to conversions and also just kind
of do these characters because they're
characters everybody loves
so um Carnage for a Spider-Man solo film
in Marvel if they did it would have to
be r at R it would have to be based on
more or less Maximum Carnage
interjecting different characters aside
from the Avengers and the X-Men and so
on
um Bruce Lee takes Onslaught no sweat
well yeah I mean hell it's Bruce Lee man
[__]
I once saw a video and this was really
funny I once saw a video of Bruce Lee
punching and uh and Bruce Lee was he was
standing like standing in position and
all he did he just he just like like
moved his shoulder forward like that and
did it with so much force that it
knocked the guy off his feet imagine an
inch away from a Target and you knock
the person off their feet like imagine
the strength that it requires to achieve
something like that that was a cool
thing about brly he could he could he
could actually like like Flex his
muscles and double his body mass like or
his body size it was it was stupid how
how like how in control of himself that
guy was that that requires an insane
amount of
discipline um let's
see Legion could beat Onslaught with
some assistance uh yeah but what you
would find if Legion were to face
Onslaught you'd find Legion jumping
through so many of his personalities
that it would be nuts um dude where is
Sentry I don't remember where Robert
Reynolds is I actually haven't fought
all the centry for a while
uh no he's dead that's right he was
killed um he was killed he was
resurrected for a Time by The Apocalypse
twins to serve as one of the uh four or
one of the horsemen of death they had
like four horsemen of death I think or
something like that and then he was
killed off again like that was a smart
move by Marvel too because they just
ever since Paul jingus and Jaye finished
the Marvel Knights run on the centry and
Gada was like let's just roll him over
into the into the main Earth 616
continuity they didn't know what to do
with this
character
they had no clue what to do with the
century the only time the century even
mattered there were only two point two
points in time when the century mattered
the first point in time was when the
century um I
guess I guess when when he first
appeared in the uh in the 2000 run of
Marvel Knights um I guess that'd be the
I guess it'd be three but that was the
first time you matter the second time
was when he was rolled over into the
continuity and uh the the combined the
combined efforts of the Avengers the
X-Men and the Inhumans could not stop
the void his alternate personality and
then the third time that he mattered was
during uh World War Hulk when he fought
Hulk to a stand aside from that he
didn't matter at all like he was just a
pointless character and every time they
would just show up and they would just
say oh my God the void's coming and it
was like oh whatever who cares no one
cares um blackbolt explain we cover
blackbolt during our video about the
Inhumans uh black panther versus Batman
that would be a good match up because
they're both insanely smart like I think
Marvel officially came out with the
ratings on the top five most intelligent
people in uh in the Marvel Comics and
black panther was right under Dr Doom
and Reed Richards so he was like third
um Batman versus original sin Nick Fury
uh man you guys are picking some tough
ones um I don't man you guys you guys
pick some tough ones okay give me a list
like okay we're going to we're going to
do this we're going to do this comic
book battles all right go through here
and give me a list of who you guys want
to see like like you guys got to pick
say I want this character like I want
these guys fighting each other like tell
me your dream match up between any two
characters and Marvel and DC Comics but
it has to be Marvel versus DC all right
it can't be like DC versus DC or Marvel
versus Marvel because that takes away
the fun of it because chances are it's
already been done
so um I'm I'm anxious to see what you
guys come up with um we will probably do
Gambit at some point I like spider
girl's costume I think spider girl's
costume is a well-designed costume it
doesn't say uh yeah no that that wasn't
Bruce Lee playing with numchucks like
I've seen that video that wasn't Bruce
Lee um Bruce Lee versus the beyonders
you guys are distracting me from the
answer I like Supergirl's costume I like
Supergirl um in terms of how she looks
in terms of the fact that if it gives
her disgree of like Authority but it
doesn't make her look like you know like
a go- go girl you know it doesn't make
her look like a woman of the night you
know it makes her look respectable which
I think is kind of a cool thing uh
Wolverine versus Lobo oh Lobo hands down
he would absolutely pmel Wolverine
because you got to think about it if you
did a story if they did a story of
Wolverine versus Lobo oh my God like all
these things are coming
in oh man um you guys are loading up
those ideas okay if if if we if if
Marvel and DC sat down and they said
okay guys we need to make a story about
Wolverine versus Lobo they're going to
give us the best set of powers lobo's
ever had in the history ofcu that means
he's going to be at maximum strength all
his capabilities are going to be there
you're going to have Wolverine who's
going to be at the Pinnacle of his
riding style so late 990s Wolverine all
right Lobo hands down like Lobo would
Pummel him but oh God see but
Wolverine's got adamantium son of a
[__] and he's got a healing Factor um
damn I don't know I might actually see
it it depends would ad mantium be able
to puncture the skin of Lobo if the
adamantium could damage Lobo then yeah
wolver rain will take it he'll just cut
his head off if adamantium can't damage
Lobo then it's a standstill because wol
rain would just recover every single
time he was beat up he would like every
punch he would almost immediately
recover from it due to his because his
healing Factor was stupid fast in the
90s like it was crazy how fast he could
recover it wasn't like these great big
huge long drawn out things in the 2000s
no it was like he got stabbed and then
almost immediately he was recovered from
it like it was silly how how intense it
was that's a good one that's actually a
pretty good one um so okay so here's a
consensus on wolver rain versus Lobo if
yeah if Lobo can be pierced by
Wolverine's adamantium then Wolverine
takes it if Wolverine cannot pierce the
the the body of Lobo then it becomes a
standstill so
um Young Avengers versus The Runaways um
I think the most important question is
does anybody care about that match up
which no I'm just passing around um I
don't I know man I don't I honestly I
haven't read either one of those in
years
uh Batman versus Black
Panther Batman versus Black Panther see
they're both extremely wealthy they're
both extremely intelligent and they're
both extremely
capable I would say black panther
because black panther draws his powers
from the panther God and at any point in
time Marvel could change the power set
Marvel could say okay if he derives his
powers from a Divine influence then now
he suddenly has the power of like to
manip like the power of that one girl
Xiao Yu from the Inhumans to manipulate
air pressure like to manipulate you know
I don't I don't know it it'd be weird um
God there's so many questions coming in
uh all right Hawkeye versus Green
Arrow oh my God you guys are picking the
hardest ones cuz you guys are picking
people who are similar okay stop picking
people who are similar don't pick the
people who are are Sim don't like Batman
versus pick the people who are not
similar like I want to see like a
difficult one okay
like Superman Silver age
Superman which was when Superman was at
his Pinnacle of abilities he could do
almost anything he could pull planets
and stuff like that Silver age Superman
versus Thanos with the power gem see
that's a good
combination
um and that's a tough
one the power gem gives Thanos infinite
power like it gives him an unlimited
amount of physical
power but Silver age Superman was nearly
Godlike in terms of what he could
do
um Deadpool versus Superman okay okay
that's what I'm talking about Pat Fiasco
that's what I'm talking
about Superman versus Deadpool who wins
in that fight okay so let's let's take
the characters at the peak of their
abilities at the at the Pinnacle of
their existence all right God there's so
many coming in right
now you guys are nuts you guys are crazy
with all your suggestions like that's
that's what I love about you guys you
guys crack me up
um all right Superman versus Deadpool so
silverage Superman silver AG Superman
could do pretty much everything like we
said you know when we were talking about
him against Thanos with the power gy
Deadpool can heal from anything um but
here's see here's the
kicker squirrel girl killed Deadpool or
defeated Deadpool and if you remember
our discussion about squirel girl the
way she did it was creating such small
incisions in his body and so many that
his body didn't recognize the incisions
his healing Factor didn't detect them
and so as a result he didn't heal and so
he ended up just
bleeding out until he was captured I got
the
burs
um I think Superman would take it
because I think Superman would be able
to create to to basically create the
same effect but see this is the
problem Deadpool can't die um we know
Deadpool can't die because
of Joe Kelly's run of Deadpool I think
maybe it maybe it wasn't Joe Kelly's run
but it was the story of Deadpool where
he he had basically um been cursed with
immortality by Thanos and so as a result
he can never
die God I don't know um itbe one of the
funniest damn fights ever okay I demand
this I am officially going on record and
saying this as part of any future
crossover event Marvel needs to Marvel
and DC need to at some point Come
Together and write a story of Superman
versus Deadpool I want to see that so
bad I want to see how that plays out in
my personal opinion when it's all said
and done it comes out to be a draw I
don't think Superman can kill Deadpool
but I don't think Deadpool can kill
Superman because Deadpool isn't in
possession of any weapons that could
physically harm Superman like there's no
way his swords would be able to harm
Superman I mean that's just not going to
happen I mean unless adamantium can hurt
Superman and we don't know
so oh God he just throws him into the
sun there you go done and
[Laughter]
done oh man God you guys are coming out
with so many things things how are the
duck versus Rocket Raccoon like I can
see you guys I can see you guys at home
right now like you guys are home home
right now giggling to yourselves just
typing in the craziest combination you
could think of I guarantee that's what
you guys are doing
um Superman could drop Deadpool on the
moon but see super like like Deadpool
couldn't die um will you continue the
MCU uh timeline anytime soon yes the
reason why I had sort of put the the
timeline on hold for a little while is
because I was waiting for Agent Carter
to end because a lot of this took place
a lot of the stuff took place in the
1930s and even then going forward
especially when we get into Age of
Ultron we don't know how far back that
movie is going to go that movie could go
way back to the era of Captain America I
mean they're going to have Baron von
strucker and so they could go all the
way back to World War II and they may
change some things and so you know I
don't want to I don't want to release
that and say okay guys like here's the
deal you know with this particular part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
have to come back and make an update to
it because it would sort of throw off a
lot of different viewers it'd be a
little confused and stuff that's one of
the reasons why we uh we put it on hold
for a little
while oh my
God Superman Prime 1 million yes but as
far as I understand he's not part of the
uh the Earth like Earth one I guess
before pre new52 he wasn't part of like
the Earth One continuity he was part of
the dc1 million
continuity I think
uh
with throw the sun into
Deadpool he'd obliterate the planet
Earth in the process but
whatever um I'm the most legit human on
earth I appreciate it
guys uh should Lobo appear big on the
big screen should appear on the big
screen how would you like him to appear
God there's so many things coming in
okay guys you guys can stop with your
list of of characters now like like
let's get back into the other questions
because now you guys are just spamming
the hell out of the
chat um
um let's
see let's go back up okay how would you
like him brought in um I definitely
think Lobo needs to appear in the uh in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I think
that the downside to Lobo appearing in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is they
wouldn't bring him in effectively um
Lobo was designed by nature to be a
parody of Wolverine that was the purpose
behind his creation um I think
ultimately if they did that
that it would take away from the effect
it would take away from how funny Lobo
could be and people would just say he's
just a spin-off of Wolverine and and
then just leave it at that um I think
that if they made a lobo film properly
or included a lobo in a film it needs to
be rated art just because of the violent
nature of Lobo especially if they go
into the origins of his character and
they talk about how he killed off
everybody in his own Society I mean I
don't I don't know it'd be um it'd be
interesting you know
uh let's see justice league dark
explained we'll get to that stuff if
it's part of the new for2 continuity we
will explain it
um let's
see isn't Lobo a DC hero
yes did I say Marvel I didn't mean to
say DC I didn't mean to say
Marvel sorry
guys lobo's DC lobo's DC I know Lobo is
DC guys I misspoke like like people were
going through and they were like hey Rob
you made the awesome like this was an
awesome video about Dick
Grayson but you kind of said Marvel at
one point in time and I'm like yep I did
okay let's
see um does the Agents of Shield series
last until the Inhumans 2018 the Agents
of Shield series is going to last as
long as they can make it
last I don't think they have a set point
where they say okay guys like this just
needs to appear in and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and it just needs to
bring in the Inhumans like once the
Inhumans are brought in then we just
don't need to worry about it anymore I
don't think that's what they're doing I
think they're just like let's make it
last as long as we
can
um let's
see my Hulk poster is crooked yeah it is
a little bit
crooked somebody's insanely
[Laughter]
OCD um do I like Marvel or DC I mean I
I've GED a new respect for DC since I
started reading it which was funny
because I had a video where I was like
oh Marvel's definitely better than DC
like DC sucks you know but like once I
actually sat down and started reading
more into DC because I remember the old
DC where every character was overpowered
and they were all just they were they
were you just couldn't identify with
them you know and you just didn't care
about their characters and stuff um the
new characters are cool like I like the
new runup DC I like them making him more
personal I like the I like one of the
things I like about DC and it was
actually Benny who really turned me onto
this
was that the great thing about DC Comics
is that there's like these massive
stories that revolve around the
characters like since Batman started
with new 52 like Scott Snyder's just
been doing like a series of amazing
batman stories Court of owls Knight of
owls um I guess the reccom with Batman
zero here which came after Batman issue
number one um let's see what was it
death of the family U Batman Eternal
Batman ingame Damien Wayne like all
these Amazing Stories in the Batman
continuity
like I have a new respect for DC Comics
[Laughter]
now
uh what do I think about the Supergirl
costume we've already talked about that
I think it's a respectable costume I
like the way it looks um are you guys
the Watchers if you want to be just
don't watch me all the time um which
Marvel Max story should I read okay
Marvel Max you should read alias
you should read Punisher and you should
read Deadpool and that's it that's all
you need to worry about with Marvel Max
um Emma Frost versus you naked I mean
that's kind of weird I mean she's a
comic book character it's kind of
creepy um let's see how did She-Hulk
become She-Hulk She-Hulk became She-Hulk
because she she was originally an
attorney um she was maintaining a case
against a mobster oh God I'm so Rusty on
this she was maintaining a case against
a mobster
the mobster tried to have her killed
while she was with Bruce Banner she was
shot and Bruce Banner gave her a blood
transfusion of his own blood which saved
her life but it caused her to turn into
the She-Hulk now originally she had the
same kind of powers as the Incredible
Hulk and that or I guess uh the same way
she transformed the Sens that it was
tied into her emotions but the problem
is that a lot of feminists got really
angry about this because what Marvel was
doing is they were saying well because
she's emotionally unstable she turns to
the She-Hulk randomly and a lot of
feminists took this to believe or took
this to mean that Marvel was saying that
women are emotionally unstable that
women just can't be emotionally stable
like men and so Marvel eventually
changed it and said that she can become
the She-Hulk at will but then they
reduced her power set and so she can
become the She-Hulk when she wants to
but she doesn't have Infinite Strength
she has like strength to a degree like
she gets to she gets strong to a point
and then she stops she can go into like
this Berserker rage which was what we
saw in Avengers uh disassembled where
she tore the vision in half and then
just started like ripping up everything
in front of Avengers Mansion now that's
my memory so I may be wrong in a couple
things but I'm pretty sure that's how
She-Hulk becomes She-Hulk
um let's see Punisher in the MCU yes and
it needs to be Thomas Jane that's the
only person who needs to play The
Punisher right now or ever like that's
it
uh in age of all Tron will Captain
America lift th's Hammer yes I can
almost guarantee that's going to happen
because people want to see it they've
hinted to that in there I think we're
going to see I think we're going to see
this epic thing I think we're going to
see this battle and Captain America is
going to be the last man standing and I
think Captain America is going to be
able to pick up Thor's hammer and like
swing it and hit Ultron with it now
whether anything actually happens to
Ultron I don't know but I think that
Captain America is going to is I mean
wouldn't that be like the icing on the
cake I mean like imagine this okay let's
let's imagine this situation let's be
fans let's be let's be fans for a second
let's
imagine that in that scene with the
trailer like the scene we saw in the
trailer where like um what was it Thor
was like is that all you've got and then
like Ultron starts sending all these
Ultron robots um after the Avengers and
they're all fighting back toback you
know and they're all they're all
fighting their hardest you know and like
Black Widow and Hawkeye are the first
ones to go down because they have no
superpowers and then after them you have
Iron Man who's like bam you know he gets
he gets slammed you know and then you've
got Thor and you've got Captain America
the last two left as improbable as it
may seem like Captain America just won't
give up like every time they knock him
down like he just you know just gets
back up again you know and so they're
puming on Thor Thor takes a few out and
then like Thor is is attacked by you
know like the vision okay let's say the
vision pops up and the vision just
starts you know just hammering on Thor
takes Thor out first because for him
he's like okay if we get rid of Thor
first Captain America's easy pickings
all right it's just it's simple from
there and so Thor's knocked out and so
then he goes after like Captain America
and Captain America I mean he's he's got
a shield like he's trying to block the
shots but but the vision's just too fast
you know and just taking him out you bam
bam bam bam bam bam you know just
knocking his ass out you know and then
eventually like Captain America just it
looks like he gets knocked out and then
like as the vision begins to walk away
you know where I guess as he begins to
gets ready to deal the killing blow like
Captain America just like slowly
staggers to his feet one last time and
then he reaches down for the first thing
he can grab and it's Thor's hammer and
he picks Pi it up and just like bam
cracks the cracks the vision with it
just snap just snaps the vision in half
you know and destroys him that way would
that not be [__]
awesome would that not be amazing like
that would be oh and the Hulk okay you
know what the Hulk will be out doing
something the Hulk will be out taking a
[__] in a field somewhere who cares
about what the Hulk's doing but that
would be amazing
um who would win in a fight by the Sea
if there were no living fish within 100
mile radius Thor versus
Aquaman or Thor but Thor is at the sea
and Aquaman is in him is in him on I
don't understand that
entirely Thor is dead because of
Ragnarok I don't know
um do I think there will ever be a Ghost
Rider movie and who will they cast no I
think that Nicholas Cage did the Ghost
Rider series irreparable harm I don't
think they can ever bring the Ghost
Rider back and make him character people
care about like people are forever going
to see Nicholas Cage is Ghost Rider and
it's going to be trash forever like it's
never going to come
back
um let's
see uh Captain America with mner for the
win he be worthy yeah even if we don't
see it in Age of Ultron we will at some
point along the line yes we'll do all
the lantern course um we will at some
point along the line see Captain America
Wheeling Thor
Tammer I can guarantee we will see
that grab your channel is so
informational thanks for all you
do you're welcome I appreciate the uh I
appreciate the support you guys are
really supportive like a lot of you guys
are really
supportive uh does it hurt your soul
knowing that we had a JLA trip XX parody
before we had the
actual I'm not answering that um Rob
picks up Thor's
hammer uh let's see yeah Nicholas Cage
ruined Ghost Rider yes he did um Rob I'm
writing an original story but what would
you rather read a graphic
novel series or a comic book
series um probably a comic book series
but I don't know maybe a graphic novel
it really it really doesn't matter to me
that much to be honest graphic novels
are better because you don't have to
have a whole bunch of little comic books
but in the end it really just kind of
depends on on the person for me it
doesn't really matter that much um
didn't they say they were going to kill
a character in age of Voltron um maybe I
don't remember them saying that maybe
they didn't I don't
remember uh secret Invasion
explained uh we will at some point
maybe your channel is the best keep up
the good work thank
you uh I am vaping um 23 sco by what is
this rag time Vapor it's a vanilla
Custard
flavor let's
see what was the point of spiderverse
there wasn't one spiderverse like
nothing happened it was
boring
um I think it was a way to just like
reconcile the spider characters and
decide which ones they wanted to bring
and to Secret Wars and which ones they
didn't I didn't like spiderverse that
much uh Dragon Ball Z your thoughts I
mean what is her to think it's like one
of the best TV shows in the history of
humanity it was part of the 90s you know
Red Robin explained yes we will get to
all that we will do all the Robins guys
don't worry like I know all you Robins
fans out there we will do all the Robins
um black widow will die I mean Scarlet
Johansson's going off to be a mom now
like I wouldn't be surprised if she was
like I don't want to do anymore so uh
Captain Britain movie for the win I mean
I don't know why they would do a Captain
Britain
movie
uh do other YouTube channels copy you
and does it infuriate you um there have
been some who have I mean there have
been there have been channels that have
copied Benny channels that have copied s
channels that have copied me I don't
think so I mean imitation is the most
sincere form of flattery but more
importantly than that we're growing a
community like like see here's here's
the cool thing guys you know I don't
mean to to sound arrogant at all but I
think that what Me by and Sal have done
with the weekly pool has really helped
to pull the community together now there
have been amazing channels out there for
quite some time like Mr Sunday movies
let me tell you guys something Mr Sunday
movies is one of the most entertaining
channels I've ever seen in my life and I
was actually surprised I was really
shocked that he didn't appear under
watch Mojo's list I was like that's kind
of dumb like definitely he should have
been top five um I mean there's variant
Comics there's there's so many great
comic book channels out there right now
and I think that we've really been able
to help bring together a lot of these
comic book channels and and sort of form
this community and I think with the
formation and and the coming together of
a lot of these big Powerhouse channels
you know with uh with I mean I don't I
don't really think I'm like a big
Powerhouse Channel I mean I think that
that channels who are huge like like big
like variant comics and stuff like that
um I think that it's helped people to
realize that they can do what we do they
can make the kind of videos we make and
they can express their love of comic
books on YouTube and have a community to
express that towards that's one of the
reasons why we launched the weekly pool
the great the great thing about the
weekly pool is that with the website
it's this big place for people to come
together and to talk about comic books
like like we have the uh The Forum I
mean if you guys haven't been there yet
like go check out the weekly pool the
weekly board and um you know we've got
this this huge Forum you know for people
to talk about comic books I mean there's
people are getting on there all the time
like one of the most common things is
like Marvel versus DC I don't know why
but we've got a Marvel section we've got
a DC section we've got a section for
independent Comics um we've got a
section for me Benny and S and super
effective we've got sections for just
general discussion and introducing
yourself I mean we've got a section for
for updates we've even got a section for
self-promotion for those of you guys who
are trying to get your channel out there
and get your channel known we've got a
we've got a section of the Forum just
for you guys so you guys can go in there
and be like hey here's who I am like
here's my YouTube channel make sure you
guys check me out you know I mean that's
one of the things that we have down
there so we've really really really
tried to make this uh for from a place
where people can be comic book fans and
go on about tangents on comic book fans
and they don't really have to feel like
well if I'm going to talk about comic
book I have to talk about the popular
stuff if you want to talk about some
obscure character from 1960 something in
Marvel Comics a character that appeared
in one issue talk about it that's what
the forum's there for so that's that's
why we have that that whole thing but um
let's
see uh Comics is the best
how strong is Adam Warlock Adam Warlock
it depends on the writing there have
been stories where Adam Warlock was the
only person who was able to survive
alongside Thanos when Thanos wiped out
all of existence like the heart of the
universe Thanos did that he wiped out
all of existence and Adam Warlock showed
up and was like dude set it back you
know there's no point in doing this and
Thanos was like yeah that's true and
then he set it all back to normal I mean
it it depends on the writers you know uh
Rob in your opinion what are the most
interesting lineups for the Avengers and
the Justice League
um what do you mean in terms of like
team formations or I'm not sure how you
mean uh what's going to make more money
Avengers or star with Star Wars Star
Wars is more of a pop culture icon than
Avengers
is but after Avengers one people want to
see the hype people want to know what's
going to happen in this one
so uh let's
see
uh in the New Avengers movie trailer was
the shot of quicksilver uppercutting
Captain America America cool or what yes
it
was
uh pre 52 is better see I hear that from
a lot of like a lot of long-term comic
book fans say that they love the new52
better but here's the thing you guys got
to consider too you guys grew up with
pre- new52 like you guys grew up with
that line of comics and so it's natural
you guys would have an affinity for that
line of comics for those of you who are
new to comic books The New 52 is where
you're going to be at like that's going
to be your
thing
here's a really good
example Back in the
Day little secrets here back in the day
I used to have a Call of Duty YouTube
channel and it was it never really grew
it had 200 subscribers at most I think
and nothing really ever came of it but
um the problem was I started with like
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 and to me
there would never be a better game than
that game I played Black Ops 1 it wasn't
as good Black Ops 2 it wasn't as good
Call of Duty ghost Advanced Warfare
wasn't as as good I even went back and
played the old games Cod 4 wasn't as
good people who started in Black Ops 1
say the same thing but they say it about
Black Ops 1 so on and so forth people
who got into that particular game got
into the particular mindset loved that
idea they stayed with that mindset and
they adapted it and that is that's
that's how comic books are people who
read 1990s Marvel Comics said no no no
no 1990s Marvel Comics is where it's at
' 90s X-Men it'll never get better than
that and anything that moves away from
that they have a problem with they don't
like and
ultimately that's just part of change
things change things grow things expand
and become different and uh and that's
just kind of people have to learn to
adapt
so um what's your pitch for a Marvel
whatif TV series Mega TV series is based
off Marvel well-known Marvel stories
what if like what if Thor was um Jane
Foster I mean that would be a great one
to start with uh uh yeah the art of the
new52 is really
good um all right how long have we' been
doing
this we've been going for oh wow we've
been going for about an hour or
so okay all right guys yeah we've been
going for about an hour um I'm GNA go
ahead and bring this to an end I need to
finish working on a video or actually
start working on a video about um about
Red Hood about Jason Todd so I'm going
to try to have that video up tomorrow no
promises um I've been talking all this
time so I'm going to need to let my
voice recover before I actually record
anything but uh but yeah so anyway um it
was awesome hanging out with you guys I
always love hanging out with you guys
and again this is going to be a Sunday
thing hopefully I want to start bringing
on like Benny and S and some of those
other guys on here uh like I think I'll
try to like I hit s up before and he
didn't answer so I was like well I guess
he's tied up or something like that but
um you know hopefully you know we can we
can get people in and uh you know get
some of the guys from the weekly pool in
and and have some fun with this so um
anyway I'm going to go ahead and bounce
off here uh with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end this
live stream to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you need let me know and I
will catch you guys later
peace I think I can end this